foreign
[Music]
hello everybody I am Nikki Novak from
Fandango and I am so excited to be
sitting down with the cast of Avatar the
way of water great to see you all and
the original cast of Avatar before we
get started into this film I want to
take a little trip down memory lane this
film it was a seminal film this film I
know when I saw it for the first time it
changed what I thought Cinema could be
and how I could experience movies you
were there but now you've had some
distance from it what was either a
moment that sort of defined that
experience for you and sort of what do
you take away from it now all these
years later
as an actor when you get down into what
we call the volume you're basically in
your you know your capture suit
and there's nothing around you there's
no world of Pandora there's only the
other actors in their little black suits
and there was a screen that Jim Cameron
put up for us where you could see a
roughed out version of yourself as what
you would look like in the finished
product in the in the world of the film
and even that I must say the first day
looking at that
magical transformation just from us
standing there I thought wow
I can't believe where this is going it's
going to be such a complete immersion of
the audience into this
foreign beautiful world and I think it
it really does that for people
absolutely a special moment
I'm pretty sure that all of us can
relate uh was getting that phone call
from Jim saying you you got the part I
really want you to play you know
uh whichever respective roles we were
going we ended up playing
for me Jake Sully yes
no but but the very first scene that we
were able to capture uh was the scene
where nateiri is as kind of like spying
on Jake Sully as he's lost and he's he's
you know he's left behind by his by his
group and um and I remember the very
first take that we did it was the the
moment that everything kind of synced
together and fell into place the from
the training to to the the language to
everything that all the endless
conversations with Jim it all culminated
in that one moment and I remember
feeling at that very moment like this is
going to be really special this is very
exciting wow it was a good meet cute
when I uh read the script originally it
was a bit like reading a novel uh Jim
Wright's in an extreme extremely and
densely uh descriptive way so it's very
novelistic and then the moment I would
get to in is when I saw the film when I
saw the Finnish film and it just the
first thing that came to me was he had
realized completely what I had read on
the page and that's a very very rare
thing to to do it seems to me and it it
pretty it blew my mind I've never uh
yeah never quite forgotten that you know
it translated absolutely wow yeah so
stepping on to set
all these years later
does it feel like a completely different
thing or did it feel familiar sort of
stepping back into the shoes because the
Technologies change you're immersed in
in water for a lot of the film and then
coming back to this family what was that
feeling like
that's a big question
[Laughter]
look avatar is like a dream to me it was
a dream to get the job but the movie was
like a dream and so we've been able to
play in this other new world but it's
just like a continuation of the dream
and now we're lucky enough to get to
share it and hopefully all those
feelings that people felt in the first
one come flooding back and then so
I think everybody is so excited I know
Zoe I don't know how much of the film
that you've all seen I think Zoe you've
talked about you've seen the first 10
minutes or James showed you the first 10
minutes and that you wept yeah and I'm
wondering and if it sort of maybe speaks
to Sigourney what you were also talking
about the first time you sort of Saw
yourself next to what Pandora would look
like how blown away our audience is even
ready for what they're going to see in
this film do they have any idea or do
you think it's going to be the same
thing as like the first time where we're
like how did somebody do you know what I
I do believe and my hope is that it'll
be the same we'll have the same reaction
that we had for Avatar one and that will
be more than okay because that was
groundbreaking already as it was so a
continuation of this it is almost as if
it's a rediscovery of Pandora because
before we got to see Pandora through the
forest
and Through The Eyes of the omotekaya
tribe and now we're stepping into the
world of the metcaina you know not V and
they are the the water people it is the
water world and I I do believe that
Pandora is very similar to Earth where
in the sense that 80 percent of that
planet is water it's a world all on its
own and it's absolutely beautiful and I
do believe that this is going to be a
like a culmination of of Jim finally
getting the opportunity to fully share
with us all his passion for the water
for the ocean he's always had it he had
it in the abyss and with Titanic
in real life with all of his excursions
uh the documentaries yeah yeah I think
whatever he saw down there he brought
back he brought back and
um and I think that through the mechaina
tribe and and their world we're going to
immerse ourselves in something that we
have never seen before and it will be
also just as groundbreaking as Avatar
one was well I actually wanted
to use upon dive a little bit deeper
into the underwater world of Pandora
what are we actually going to see what
kind of creatures can we expect to see I
know James has talked a little bit about
when he goes down to the bottom of the
ocean it's almost like being on another
planet
um can you talk maybe Sigourney about
that what are we going to experience
visually well we we were able to see 13
minutes at uh d23 and I would say a lot
of that was underwater
it was so real and seemed to fill the
entire theater that I actually felt my
feet moving as if I had to tread water
just to stay uh as part of it I think
it's even more mind-blowing than the
first one because it's just such a new
element for us as human beings to feel
comfortable under water and um to to to
feel a connection with the the creatures
that that live underwater it's very much
I think what Jim would dream of if he
could if he could create any experience
for us to to to give us the ability to
be underwater without needing to breathe
and he's given it to us here and in such
a breathtaking way
people will never want to leave the
theater honestly they'll just want to
sit there and see it again and again
because it's it's something you can't
get in real life yeah you know maybe you
can speak a little bit too and I know
James isn't here to talk about the sort
of the technical aspect of it but little
things like the frames per second that
normally in a film it's like 26 and this
film it's sped up so sort of give people
that real immersive feel that you're
talking about so can you talk a little
bit about sort of how you work as an
actor when you're when it's probably the
most ambitious movie ever made how does
that change for you your performance as
an actor does it make it more
complicated for you I think that it's
probably the more sophisticated or or
complicated the technology probably the
the wise thing to do is to simplify
simplify simplify as an actor keep it
simple stupid that's my motto when I get
in there but but but truthfully I mean
the uh the environment that's always
been created for us and actually we're
all sitting where we are right now is
stage 27 here where and we did the bulk
of our work In This Very Room really
yeah
I believe that right where we are right
now Sam and I probably fought it out
with a chain in our hand at some point
but but
um the uh the atmosphere the conditions
that were always created for us were
always I think as beneficial to the
actors they as they could possibly be I
mean what we do as actors is such a
peculiar thing in the first place we
pretend for a living
that any circumstances are weird it
seems to me you know and I'm not sure
that that you know the volume is any
stranger than any other circumstance in
fact because of the nature of the room
itself which is actually kind of a bare
bone situation it really calls upon you
to just exercise your the powers of your
own imagination to create create
it seems to me so I don't know if that
answers the question but it's what I
wanted to say well aside from being in
this incredible Sound Stage that now I
feel like I'm a part of History here you
did a lot of free diving there was a lot
called upon all of you as actors to do
something you've never done before and
using a technology and that's filming
underwater with these performance
capture suits we were the guinea pigs
were going to get zapped because you go
to your power packs on Jim's son get in
the water it's never been done before so
I thought we were going to get fried
okay sir so I understand that Kate
Winslet broke the record she beat Tom
Cruise's record for the number of
minutes filming a scene underwater she
did seven minutes I want to know how you
all did Rip Kate
that's why she's not here today
but how what do you experience where Did
you sort of begin and your ability to
hold your breath I think it was about a
year of training where did you end up
and what does it actually feel like
performing underwater and how do you
emote underwater how do you act well we
worked we worked with a world-renowned
uh expert Kirk for months we studied for
about a year we started you know just
getting certified for scuba and I
remember even the first day he he has
you be very still with your face in the
water and we were able to hold our
breath for a minute
which surprised me and then he continued
to build on that do doing breathing up
exercises and you also have the benefit
of enhanced oxygen when you're actually
shooting the movie so that um breathing
up on 80 oxygen in your life there's
only at least 50 yeah so your the amount
that your of oxygen your blood cells are
taking
it allows you to be under there longer
but it's all about calm and meditative
which you know Sigourney is a half fish
it's incredible
my husband is half fish and I want it to
be half fish but I'm I'm maybe a quarter
fish now yeah thank you so to to ask the
question about how do you how difficult
is it to act underwater to emote
um it was never an easy thing at least
for me
um but having the tools
and going through all the breathing
exercises and knowing that I was
surrounded by uh people that at any
given second
we're gonna do whatever they can to make
sure that I was safe
it does put you in a meditative sort of
you know place where you surrender
I think that surrendering was was the
key factor that my body needed in order
for me to be able to be relaxed down
there and by by surrendering I was able
to always practice all the tools because
it wasn't just that we were under the
water we were also going you know 20 25
up to 30 feet right was it ever 30 feet
30 feet was the maximum the tank is 30
feet deep and when you're doing that
like every five to eight feet you're
you're equalizing so your main because
as your your lungs are are feeling you
know the pressure of the depth you have
to equalize to make sure that you're
fine to the by time you get there and
they do the countdown and they say
action
you know you're going to give Jim at
least 45 seconds to a minute and a half
of good performance so I needed to break
it all down your brain's wigging out all
the time just race to the surface when
you're 30 feet deep your body will just
explode so yeah it's all about a lot of
pressure no a lot of pressure it's all
pressure but uh but you have to be calm
and I think that it was for me it was
the toughest thing I've ever had to do
and then to be down there and know that
if you're doing an action scene
underwater you're going to be burning
your energy at a quicker rate so you're
going to run out of whatever oxygen your
body has left and then to do an
emotional scene and your brain's talking
to you too much and you're wigging out
and you don't want to look like a
blowfish you're trying to be calm and
just connect with your fellow actor
who's gone through the same process down
there so it was to be honest that's the
toughest thing I've ever had to do in my
life it all starts with the static hold
which is the as Sigourney said it was
the first thing you did and when you do
the static hold you're just immersing
your face face in the water and
everything is supported you don't have
to spend any energy keeping your arms up
or anything like that it's a savasana in
a sense and it's something you can you
can return to time and time again and
and interestingly enough it's kind of
the one thing from the water that I
think I've taken away from me also is
that I think static hold quite a lot in
my on an airplane sometimes I kind of
call it static hold now I'm on static
hold I think it's a good lesson for life
if we're ever in the water yeah
um so I want to talk about your
characters some of you are playing new
characters some of you returning to
character I want to start with you
Sigourney because Gary I'm fascinated by
her because I understand that Jim came
to you and said I want you to play a
teen girl you're perfect for the role
what does he know about you that we
don't and one question I'm a little
worried about that myself from what I
understand you went to you had like a
workshop with teens you did parkour can
you talk about sort of getting into
character for this one well I do know
Jim pretty well and he has you know
known him over the years and he knows
that I'm
basically a silly person even though I
may seem serious and so uh and I think
he is too I mean that's the big surprise
about Jim because you think oh he's so
intimidating and scary and serious but
he's actually you know he's a pussycat
and he's very very funny so you know we
can be quite immature together and I
think he just
I was very touched that he would think
that um that I could play this part I
had an immediate connection with her
because I remember that time in my life
when I when I was that age but I also
think that she is at that age where she
feels much happier to be in the forest
with with the plants and everything she
feels much more comfortable there than
with in society with people where she
she doesn't feel secure and um I just
think I had to luckily we had we had
quite a bit of time because we kept
postponing but I was able to kind of go
back and really
immerse myself in what it felt like to
be that age I did go and check out some
classes at a high school because I
wanted to hear the range of voices you
know the pitch of voices and 14 is very
interesting because you have such a
range of you know people from you know
they still seem very childlike with with
High voices to you know the same age
person could be you know very mature
looking and sounding so it kind of made
me feel like I could just follow Kyrie's
lead and come up with whatever it was
right for her does Kerry have a
connection to Dr Grace Augustine at all
is there any sort of like was there any
sort of transference or I don't know if
that's a spoiler point or plot point or
is there a connection at all there is a
connection okay and you have to go see
the movie to know exactly what it is but
there is a very strong connection where
is this relationship we left off happily
ever after they're now married they're
now together they have family together
are they still having date night are
they still
they actually are are they we did the
same but they would they should not be
having because they have so many kids
so how have these characters evolved
since the last film oh it's the ultimate
love story you know the
two different worlds and they found each
other and the the natural progression as
you always say was to go forward with
the family and it's a family that
they've made and created and that
they've chosen as well
and you know and that's to me that was
the the heart of the story is this
protection of this family of the
protection of this love which is very
important when it's under stress you
know Jake's split again is he going to
protect his family on one side or is he
going to step up and protect the Navi on
the other side where does his
responsibilities lie and so that was the
that's his dilemma in this movie yeah
and I and their relationship is
definitely one for the books they are
Partners they are
um in love uh trying to you know have a
life together in a time of War as well
as you can see from the footage that was
just shared you know War just keeps
knocking out their door and they have no
choice now but to protect their children
but by protecting them are they
preparing them also you know that's that
so they're they are going to be
challenged as a family in terms of what
what the idea of of love and battle is
and um and they're going through normal
parental stuff too the kids are talking
back to them they're talking back
they're disobeying they're
you know and and so and so they're going
through the struggles that every parent
goes through as you said in a time of
extreme stress and battle of a planet
yeah and material once again has to you
know find it in her heart to
give or or work with these these
Invaders that are never going to go away
it's like a fungus it doesn't matter
where you stop it it's going to keep
growing from someplace else and and I I
do believe that her
her challenges will be to to still make
room just just the way AWA has taught
her to still make room for for that kind
of you know compassion that she really
just doesn't naturally have for these
humans he took two arrows to the chest
in the last film he's back
I wasn't going to say it but I thought
that when you said it you've mentioned
that this character spent some time in
hell and now he's back he's regrouping
he's regrouped and now he's back
um you play you have you play the form
of an avatar this time so this changed
your performance I'm sure as well is he
more evil than ever what is he what is
he dealing with this time I would never
use the word evil myself but
um misunderstood that's how we were I
wouldn't use the word misunderstood
either what I would say is that whatever
that that courage is born and reborn
under the same aggressively Wayward star
that quartz is
um his world his DNA his his his he saw
us everything about him is destined for
combat for aggression it's I don't know
what to say other than that that that's
almost a physical trait for him he can
do no more he can do no less than that
his name quarrich rhymes with war he's
got an itch for war it's quarrel it's
everything about it is he's um yeah and
that has not changed
that he's brought that fundamental
courageousness to him in his new
Incarnation but what has changed is that
this new Incarnation is is Pandora
and all of that is implied what it's AWA
it's the uh the life and fluid nature of
water I've always felt that that that
that Pandora
represented kind of a fluid and movement
and and curves whereas courage was
always meant to be right angles he
always moved it he thinks in right
angles he moves in right angles but that
is now his conflict is that yeah that's
all there but there's this other stuff
coming in there too which is the I maybe
it's AWA I don't know what it is so I
want to ask about the 3D James sort of
redefines 3D how is this how is sort of
the technology evolved in the sense of
like how much different is it going to
look from the first one how much more
how is this the only way for audiences
to experience this film is in 3D in your
opinion no no he's look stories always
Jim's main Viewpoint he loves technology
advancements so obviously I'm with 3D
he's always looked at it as an immersive
quality I think when you're doing a
story that a lot of it is set underwater
that immersive quality is really going
to take an audience from their seat into
as you said Treading Water you know
having to you're feeling like you might
have to hold your breath I think he's
he's using the skills and tools and that
he's you know worked on for years and
has discovered and has actually made the
cameras for to take that audience out of
their seat and into Pandora and that was
always what he wanted to do but you're
only going to stay in Pandora if the
storyline is strong and the characters
are empathetic so but I think you we'll
have to you know you have to experience
this in the theater and the I think one
of the reasons that it took a long time
was that he was actually waiting for the
technology to catch up to his vision so
as breathtaking is the first experience
was and is visceral I think this is even
more ambitious and even more remarkable
um and it it sets 3D
you know into a whole new realm it
really took my breath away to watch it
yesterday just the 13 minutes we saw I
thought oh my God what a glorious return
to the theaters we will have because you
can only have this excitement joy and
everything else when you are in the
theater watching it in 3D and as we wrap
up what what do you hope audiences are
going to feel or what do you what do you
think the reaction is going to be when
they see this and then we always want
more can you tease a little bit for the
following Avatar and will we see you in
four and are we potentially thinking of
five none of us are allowed to answer
that question
you know we'll get two to the chest
um like you said no obviously the the
wish is always for more this is
something that we have enjoyed making we
have we feel humbled to be a part of we
also enjoy watching and witnessing
um with audiences so
um three is going to be a continuation
of two
and I I hope that this makes sense I
know this is as much as I have to say
but and what you will have is an
experience that will be Unforgettable
lingering
in in other words uh it will be
groundbreaking it will be gut-wrenching
it would be beautiful it will be you
know uh it'll just be really profound
and if if two is able to Captivate you
and the way that one did then then just
please wait for three because it's so
much better too and you know as much as
we may talk about the technology and I
frankly can't begin to describe how it's
changed ever uh I'll be just like any
other uh spectator when I when I see it
um just in awe but I think the story
that starts after one starts with two
builds to three and then four and then
five is so
involving and when you come out of the
theater yes you have had an amazing
physical experience transformative but
what you'll be thinking about is the
characters you spend time with their
their situation and their bonds with
each other as well as this new world you
get to see I think it's so much about
the story always with Jim that's what
you take out with you yeah I think he
spent four years writing the scripts
from what I heard I mean that's a huge
undertaking I hope we will see the line
I see you make a comeback
perhaps
yes it's coming back anything new any
new catchphrases we should look out for
I'm sure but you'll also have your you
know you're famous
gowns and yeah yeah yeah I see you means
everything it doesn't just mean that I
see you it means I love you it means
hello it means a number of things
the way the first film sort of opened
and closed with was on your eyes and
being seen very last question what do
you think the theme of this film is
going to be if the last film was sort of
you know finding your way in the world
and finding who you are and what your
place is what is the theme of this one
protecting that yeah I think in the end
it's for me it's always love yeah it's
always love family you know it's a
complex group of people and their love
for each other their their disagreements
all these things I feel like Jim has a
family that means so much to him so much
of what's on the page and so much of
what we brought to it is a reflection of
his love for his family and his
enjoyment of their particular qualities
characters you know
he was always talking about you know he
really wanted us kids to be to to
reflect what he saw at home and so we
kind of just went at it you know like
the brats we were meant to be